Are Millennials more prone to burnout than other generations?
The answer is maybe
but not because they're Millennials.
It's not some biological thing that
an entire generation is more prone to burnout than a previous generation.
I don't think that's it at all
but I think that the trend of how we live our lives is very different.
I think we are more solitary in how we live our lives.
And there's good data that there's fewer marriages,
there's fewer people living together,
people are staying single longer
and even the quality of relationships
which I've talked about
and others have talked about as well
where social media and cell phones sometimes interrupt and get in the way
and frustrate our ability to form those
deep meaningful relationships.
Millennials just by virtue of when they were born
and what technologies were available that day
were sort of on the front line
the first ones to grow up in this world
and these trends.
And so I think that the opportunity to ask for help
or accept help when it's offered,
to express that kind of vulnerability
to deal with that kind of stress.
I mean think about how easy it is when there's a  conflict with another human being.
It's just much easier to ghost them than to have a confrontation, right?
You've been dating somebody for a while, you're really not into it anymore.
Instead of gaining closure and having a conversation,
even a fight,
we just disappear.
Why?
Because it's easier. Let's be honest.
But I think that actually not only hurts the
other person
it actually creates loneliness for us.
Sometimes those confrontations, even if they're difficult, are valuable.
There's some good data on this—
that somebody who gets ignored at work,
when their boss never talks to them,
they never get any kind of positive feedback,
never kind of negative feedback.
I can't remember exact numbers but
it's something like seven percent are engaged in their work.
It's an overwhelmingly high number of people are disengaged
simply because they get no positive or negative feedback
and if they were to get in trouble,
their level of engagement actually goes up.
And if we get one piece of positive feedback from our bosses
our level of engagement quadruples or something like that.
In other words
getting negative feedback actually
makes us more engaged in our work than
getting no feedback
because at least somebody knows we exist and that's the point.
I think one of the reasons that this generation
and maybe younger generations
and again not as a result of the generation thing
but rather the the life in which they've grown up
just by virtue of when they grow up
probably does make them more prone to burnout.
Probably because they find themselves
doing more things themselves.
That the concept of partnership or help is reduced.
So when you have more to do,
when you have more on your plate,
you have to be the breadwinner,
the homemaker ... all of this,
of course we're going to burn out more.